Guillermo I want to start with something
that I didn't know that you started as a
young man working in animation not in
live action you I think your brother and
your then girlfriend were making a movie
with puppets yeah started the film did
not end well what happened well what
happened is I had already taught
animation and I've done stop-motion and
claymation and we were preparing my
first feature and we did over a hundred
puppets and sets and we were shooting
the first day I was on a mating it we
went for dinner and we came back to our
studio had been burglarized and they
have crushed every single puppet there
was nothing of value so they stomped
every puppet to the ground and they
proceeded to defecate mp on the floor on
the puppets yes which fully prepared me
for Hollywood so I I was I was ready to
form a form part of this industry so
that was your lesson try live action not
animation yes
um and then but then I came back I was a
DreamWorks for almost a decade producing
called directing writing and developing
three series eight movies and so on Mark
I want to ask you about the
opportunities and challenges that
stop-motion present because there's
something that is captured emotionally
in performance and by the way the
animators on this film I would say are
just as good as the voice actors in
terms of performance and animators
generally don't get that kind of credit
but Mark I want to ask you about how you
took the emotional power of stop-motion
animation and given that you have
limitations what that presented in terms
of opportunities and challenges to to
tell this story
well first of all I think
Guillermo's first experience in stop
motion was so traumatizing I knew
I knew we could probably do a little bit
better
the floors were clean
yeah you know we were really trying to
give agency over these performances back
to the animators as much as possible and
we did a whole lot of things in order to
make that happen the first thing we did
was we went out and we got the best
possible animators that we could that we
could find another thing we did was we
decided to go with mechanical faces as
opposed to replacement faces for the
vast majority of the characters and what
this meant was that the animators had
more control more Nuance they could
breathe into the performances like in
the moment they could make changes as
they saw fit so you know we would brief
them and we would say this is what we
need from this shot we have to hit this
this this is what the character's
thinking
and because that was the most important
thing
it doesn't matter well motion matters
right but what the character's thinking
matters even more and that's what
they're thinking not expressed through
dialogue there's there's
Linger on faces yeah we're talking about
right vital to this so we always
preached Eyes First Eyes First Eyes
First
and what are the logistics of a day's
shoot you're on how many different
stages how long does it take to get
let's just say 10 seconds of animation
a thousand shooting days yeah and we
would get about uh you know if all went
according to plan we would get about
three seconds a week out of our
animators uh so yeah I know when the
studio says what do you got you say we
have three seconds this week every
morning we will look at three seconds
but also we work with over 60 units at
the same time yeah at the shooting at
the consecutively so Alexander was
watching the credits go by and your uh
your orchestrations and your
instrumentation lots of violas lots of
violins
and not a lot of things that people bang
on or made out of metal and I'm
wondering was that part of the
inspiration to try to create music
through wood instruments as much as
possible yeah this was the idea
Pinocchio is a little boy made of wood
and we I suggested to a game with it we
could try and have an orchestra only
made of wood you know violins Chile Basi
pianos Harps recorders Woodwinds there's
plenty actually plenty of instruments
were just even the accordion is made of
wood so
um I'm sure nobody notices but it
creates a sound that subconsciously it
just just reminds you that it's um it's
a it's the the world of wood that we're
watching I noticed Georgina your title
is director of character fabrication
with sound which sounds so industrial
and it's so beautiful and magical and
personal so I'm going to ask you about
about that fabrication these puppets are
one sixth scale right yeah the one sixth
scale which sort of Pinocchio is around
about nine and a half inches tall and
that's all about what is the best scale
for an animator to be able to get the
best performance out of a puppet so
everything was based around Pinocchio
you know we made him the perfect scale
and then Geppetto's a little larger and
it also the the scale was really decided
with once we decided we were going to do
head mechanics we needed enough space in
the heads to put all of the articulation
points in there and for the animator to
be be able to actually access those
articulation points as well so our actor
on the panel Brian
um amazing performances when you are
looking for people who are going to work
with you that feels like a very unusual
call because a there might not be a lot
of stop-motion animators round B they're
going to jump at the chance to get back
in the game so how do you assemble a
cast of animators and do they bring
different skills to different characters
starting with the skills yes they
absolutely do
um I think the
um like Pinocchio was probably created
by one of our two youngest women
animators uh in the way that they just
took him on and and brought him to a
place that some of my older male
colleagues couldn't have done because
they bring new energy to it so I think
that's definitely so so you get you get
the personality as well as you do with
the live action actor you get
personalities uh with the animator as
well
um how to get them well you say
Guillermo del Toro's name and they they
are flocking
luckily Portland has become this harp of
stop-motion animation because of Leica
with like and will Billington before
that uh yeah so Shadow machine moved up
there because of this talent pool up
there
um and yeah as Mark says we were lucky
to get some of the absolute best in the
field Scott I'm going to ask you about
sound design because the movie itself is
in that kind of odd place between
reality and artificiality
um we heard from Alexan about how he
orchestrated his his players
what were the rules if any for you and
sound design how much was real how much
was created how much was environmental
how much was synthetic you know the big
thing we did we needed to start with
wood
so Guillermo and I talked about trying
to find vintage puppets and we got some
of them together and they started
selling bowling pins so they were too
heavy so that I contacted a guitar
manufacturer and got exotic woods and we
started putting that together and we
said okay this is good but then
Geppetto's got wood clogs Pinocchio's
got wood some of the puppets have wood
we had a lot of wood so
um then at that point we said okay how
about squeaks and how about uh Rubber
and putting metal squeaks in so anytime
you see Pinocchio it's probably
10 different sounds going on at once so
it never just it never overstayed its
welcome with wood clacking so sometimes
like even the end where he goes the
hands just
just and it was you have to find the
right sound so it wasn't like yeah gotta
get some wood
so there's nowhere for us to hide
all every sound had to be the right
sound and I'd work with garam on some
really big loud shows and this was all
about jazz this was all about
find the one sound that works not the 20
sounds then make up a sound and just try
in any given moment it's all about being
delicate working within the story
working against the great music and and
just adding that that bit of realism
that creates a Sonic signature for the
for the different characters but also
the instruction was very clear I said we
cannot do a live action mix on an
animation movie I said we have to be
small and otherwise it The Sound will
sound like a different movie than the
image so and and and the mix I would say
give me the names of the track try go
and track them one three four six seven
out yeah and then it's about it sounding
the same size as the puppet and my last
question is about all the things that it
brings together that are important to
you about people who have been
marginalized or cast aside you have
creatures Spirits monsters you have
Fascism and you also even have like
freak Show circus performers which you
did recently yeah did this book speak to
you from a very young age because it
does feel like this is almost a
culmination of everything you've
explored in all of your other films when
I was when I saw this was the second or
third movie I saw with my mother as a
kid and it was the first time I failed
somebody understood how scary childhood
was that's what I got from the movie but
I've been trying to make this movie this
particular movie we started talking
about it with Grace Rim in 2002. and we
were fully form and rejectable by every
studio in town in 2008 or nine everybody
said this is before Pan's life yeah it's
2004 right yeah
around 2004 I bought art from his book
and we started saying let's do it with
the handsome company and then Lisa
supported that idea and we went on into
trying to make it and it would be it's
very hard to explain to people that
animation can be an adult even if it has
comedy or this and that and they said is
it for kids I said no but kids can watch
it if their parents talk to them you
know which is very different so it
culminates many feelings of mixing
things like Ben's Labyrinth and this and
that but it is unique in that animation
can access a beauty and a truth uh that
is not accessible in any other form of
film what do I mean by that we can reach
such Pinnacles of Purity and beauty and
truth and at the same time they are
impossible in in the real world so
there's a sense of beauty and loss and
Truth all at the same time that is
incredibly moving and powerful and no
other form and if I may close with this
uh it is stop-motion is a one animation
art that is very parallel to live action
it's real sets real props all age
cinematography movement linear movement
but I think of stop-motion
as Ginger said about Fred Astaire she
said I do what you do but backwards and
in high heels so that's the stop motion
for you
and my only hope is that the people who
robbed your your studio and smash your
puppets have come to understand that
puppetry is okay and not something to
smash together smash apart and pee on
which that and frankly better digest him
from the evidence that was left
um I want to thank Guillermo Mark
Alexander Georgina Brian and Scott and
all of you for coming out thank you
thank you thank you very much
[Applause]